[Music]
hi everybody i'm tim schaefer from
double fight productions here today to
take a deeper look
into psychonauts 2. psychonauts 2 was an
action adventure game starring rasputin
aquato
a powerful young psychic also trained
acrobat
ran away from a circus home to join the
psychonauts and expand
and explore his psychic abilities one of
raz's most important psychic abilities
is that of astral projection which
allows him to project his psyche into
someone else's mind and see their mental
landscape made real
he can help them wrestle with their
inner demons and fight their actual
nightmares
in person which means that the levels in
the game are actually
brains and psychonauts 2 has even more
brains than the first game
one of the first brands you'll get to
visit is that of caligosto lobato now dr
lobato was actually a villain in the
first
game but after roz fought him they kind
of became friends
he actually has a piece of information
that raz wants which is who kidnapped
truman zonato and dr lobato wants to
tell you but he can't
because of something going on deep in
his unconscious mind so raz has to
travel along with sasha
mia and coach olander into his mind and
try to extract that information
and there's a lot of forces at work
inside lovato's mind may be put there by
someone else
who are trying to stop you including
some of the the enemies that you might
recognize from the first psychonauts
game including the sensors
entities designed to stamp out thoughts
that don't belong in someone's mind
including raz who doesn't belong here
they also see a lot of new enemies
such as doubts and regrets lovato's mind
is plagued with thousand regrets and
they're very dangerous for razz
did i mention there's a lot of teeth
have i mentioned there's a lot of teeth
there's a lot of teeth
he's an amateur dentist he doesn't know
a lot about teeth but he really really
likes them
luckily to fight all these enemies razz
will have his psychic powers
including his powerful psychic punch
where he has his hands that extends
secondly from his body
into a powerful melee combo he also has
a psychic blast where he can shoot a
powerful energy beam out of his brain
razz also has the ability of pyrokinesis
it's always handy to be able to burn
things
with your mind and levitation raz can
use his own thoughts his own
thought bubble over his head as a
balloon to float around or ride around
on
to get somewhere really quickly so with
these new powers raz can fight
all these new enemies and hopefully find
out who kidnapped truman zonato
now while truman's been kidnapped the
person running the psychonauts is
hals forsyth the second head of the
psychonauts hollis is also the head of
the interim program
which is what raz has joined now that
he's become part of the psychonauts
and he is invited into hollis's brain
for instruction
hollis is teaching him a new psychic
ability called mental connection where
you can see two thoughts in someone's
mind and connect them
sometimes creating new thoughts making
new things happen while raz is training
a mental connection inside of
hollis mental classroom he experiments a
little too far
and accidentally maybe slightly on
purpose creates
a lot of interest in gambling inside of
hollis mind because he wants to go on
the mission to the lady octopus casino
unfortunately this connection leads to
more connections and eventually the
whole thing gets out of raza's control
and
hollis gets way too interested in
gambling and
raz has to go back into her mind where
he finds out that
her memories of medical school and where
she studied neurology
have been corrupted by this gambling
interest and it becomes a
casino hospital and raz has to actually
go in there and engage with all these
gambling machines in order to shut it
down and return holster's mind back to
normal
and she's gonna be she's gonna be really
mad inside hollis's mind you'll see
bigger tougher sensors
that have turned into bouncers inside
the casino and also a new enemy called
bad idea with bad ideas
uh spawn actual nasty looking light
bulbs over their head that become
dangerously explosive and blow up in
razz's face
now headquarters one of the things that
happens in psychonauts 2 that's most
exciting to razz is that he gets to
visit the headquarters of the
psychonauts themselves
which is called the mother lobe this is
the center for all psychonauts
activity and razz gets to see his old
friend sasha and mia who are counselors
at summer camp in the first game
he now gets to see where they work he
gets to see their offices he gets to see
their labs he gets to see their
co-workers
other agents in the field but also he
gets to see the admin and maintenance
staff as they go about their business
and hang out in the cafeteria
and sort of the everyday happenings of
uh
what life what appears to be normal in
the psychonauts world there are a lot of
little hidden pathways and treasures
around the base that he can find
side quests and scavenger hunts and
things that you might recognize from the
first game
there's a lot of characters to meet a
lot of fun things to discover a lot of
secrets about the psychonauts themselves
and the lore of the founding the
psychonauts including the psychic six
who were seen on stumps around the
campfire in the first game but now we
get to go
much deeper into the story of how they
played a part in the founding of the
psychonauts
um how they were brought together and
recruited by ford crawler and turned
into this amazing international
espionage force one of the things that
was so important about the first game
was exploring this natural environment
around the summer camp
all the little hidden paths and caves
where raz's adventures took place
and so in the second game we've expanded
on that there's an even bigger natural
environment multiple natural
environments around the headquarters
that you can explore
there's a quarry outside the mother lobe
which is where they dug out these
massive deposits of titanium titanium
this
psycho-reactive mineral that amplifies
and changes psychic powers there's lots
of
secrets around the quarry lots of
abandoned mines and caves and
things to explore and next door to the
quarry
is an abandoned roadside attraction
called the questionable area
a sort of power vortex of strange
happenings which is also caused by the
titanium deposits in the area
water flows uphill animals behave
strangely
there's caves dedicated to the mystery
of the sasquatch
which is a giant one-eyed being that
might have existed and might not have
here in the question by area raz's
family has camped out his entire family
as if to embarrass him in front of his
new psychologist's friends
his family has showed up and they want
him back in the circus
it turns out some of his family members
including his own father have a little
bit of psychic power themselves
and they'll be exploring that in second
months too and you'll get to find out
who put this curse on raza's family to
die in water
the aquatos have been cursed by a
mysterious character to all die in water
and this manifests itself in the form of
the hand of golokyo
which is this hand that comes out of the
water which is really just raz's
second construct raz is so afraid of
water because of the curse put on his
family
that every time he comes near water this
creepy hand comes out and tries to grab
him and pull him under which is all
happening inside of
rather's head in second house two you'll
get to find out who put this curse on
raz's family
where it came from and what he can do
about it the story you uncover about the
curse put on raza's family
links back into the story of the
foundation of the psychonauts and raz
finds out that his family and the
psychonauts family
are actually more intertwined than he
believed so there's a lot of mystery to
discover for the player
and raz and his family and his friends
as they
explore the connections between his
family and the psychonauts and what all
has to do with
maligula maligula is a one of the first
villains psychonauts ever fought she's a
powerful psychic and she's a mass
murderer
and she's been believed to be dead for
many years but there's
a lot of unknown things going on behind
the scenes and a lot of mysteries
and a lot of plots for the player to
uncover in psychonauts too
so that's it thanks for taking this
deeper look into psychonauts 2 with me
the game is coming out
august 25th and you can pre-order now
so i'll stop talking so you can go and
do that thanks for watching